let's do it as we always do rapid fire
one at a time
through four different awards let's
begin with the offensive player of the
week mds you are up
i've got deandre hopkins with the hail
murray catch
which was outstanding but you know he
was having a good game already he ended
up with seven catches
for 127 yards and when you look at the
connection
that hopkins and kyler murray have i
really wonder if we're going to look
back on this trade as
from the perspective of the cardinals
or is one of the worst trades in nfl
history from the perspective of
texas yeah i absolutely agree with you
mds i said that earlier herschel
walker's the only thing that comes close
to that
i'm gonna go you didn't have to mention
it again you really didn't have to
mention
i did it for fun yeah absolutely uh i'm
gonna go with with alex smith the
greatest comeback story maybe
in nfl history it's hard to argue that
after 17 surgeries to save his life and
save his life
and he probably would have gotten the
award just getting back on the active
roster and he certainly would have
gotten it just by
showing up and taking a snap in a game
but he has done
way more than that set career highs in
attempts completions and yards this week
first time ever i was surprised at this
that he had back he has had back to back
300 yard games he's been really good for
washington and ron rivera said hey maybe
we have
our quarterback the future we're going
to see i know he's older but
god he's playing great and it's so fun
to see alex smith doing what he's doing
yeah it really is and look i have to go
with the guy who quickly is becoming my
favorite player in the national football
league kyler murray
for all the reasons we discussed earlier
shireen the the throw
that won the game the way he runs the
football the way he does
everything it is just so much fun to
watch him and i feel like i felt a
couple of years ago when patrick mahomes
was first
exploding onto the scene where i
couldn't get enough
i hope i don't get numb to kyla murray
the way i've gotten numb to patrick
mahomes i have a feeling that we will
but i think here's the difference we're
not being
fed a huge dose of kyler murray yet this
year there's not a lot of prime time
games for the arizona cardinals maybe
we'll see a lot of postseason action
for the cardinals maybe next year is the
year that we start to get desensitized
to what kyle murray does maybe there'll
be somebody else who comes along who
does it even better i don't know
but i'm as excited about kyler murray
this year as i was about mahomes
probably more he is so much fun to watch
and and there really is this sense of we
don't know which way it's ultimately
going to go this season for them are
they going to win the division
are they going to be a one seed are they
gonna stumble and fall a couple of times
and maybe not even make the playoffs
there's a lot of good teams in the nfc
and they've got them chasing at their
heels so
uh what whatever happens it's just
fun watching colin murray play is fun
and uh i say there's probably never
going to be another one like him but i
said that two years ago about patrick
mahomes
i mean i guess one of the reasons i'm so
excited about football now you've got
this year after year there's another guy
who enters the league who just wows us
and i hope that continues year in and
year out
for as long as we're following the game
all right let's get on to the defensive
player of the
of the week not the year but of the week
he could be defensive player of the year
as well mds you're up first
well i'm going with jalen ramsey and you
know i love trades like the deandre
hopkins trade when you can get a great
player without giving up much
i'm usually a little more skeptical of
these trades where you give up two
first-round picks
like the rams did for jalen ramsey and
then of course you also have to give the
guy
a big contract that's going to go a long
way on your salary cap but
these are the games you trade for a guy
like jalen ramsey for
big divisional game you put him on the
other team's best receiver
and he shut down dk metcalf and shutting
down dk metcalf
goes a long way towards shutting down
the seahawks offense the rams
won a big game with big playoff
implications
i think jalen ramsey was the single
biggest reason for that
and i think we saw exactly what the rams
were envisioning
when they make that trade transpire on
sunday
mds i'm going to stay on the same team
and because jaylen ramsey
locked down dk metcalf like he did
darius williams saw a lot of action
and he had as many catches from russell
wilson as dk metcalf
did he had two interceptions and played
just great and i think they have a great
pairing there with those two and oh by
the way
he had a pick six that was called back
by an offsides now maybe russell wilson
doesn't take that throw knowing it was
offsides but nonetheless
darius williams also played great in
that game that rams defense was terrific
against russell wilson and seahawks you
know this is like a slot machine we've
got
three boxes let's pretend we're pulling
the arm
right and so mds is spinning and it
stops on ugly ass rams logo
shireen stops on ugly ass rams logo and
mine stops on
ugly assram's logo i don't know what
you'll win but this is the first time
all year that we've got
all three from the same team i'm gonna
go with leonard floyd he had three sacks
and if you're gonna focus on keeping
aaron donald
from sacking your quarterback hey
there's a chance somebody else
on that defensive front is going to do
it floyd the guy they brought in to
to take advantage of the opportunities
that are there when defenses
or when offenses excuse me try to keep
aaron donald in check
floyd i got to give him credit he got
the three sacks
part of the effort to neutralize the
seahawks offense
and you know guys something we talked
about earlier today on pft live and
we're trying to diagnose the problems
with the seahawks
they really do have to get more creative
about getting the ball in dk metcalf's
hands
especially for games like this if he's
going to be covered down the field
throw the quick screen put him in motion
do a jet sweep
do something to get the rams defense off
off its axis
uh otherwise you're gonna have an
outcome like the one that we saw where
the rams defense was just
awesome at every level on sunday against
the seahawks all right rookie of the
week time mds who do you have
i have justin jefferson who had 135
yards on monday night against the bears
he's currently leading the nfl with 18.1
yards per catch
is emerging as i think the best receiver
in a good rookie class
of receivers and you know we've been
talking about trades
and i'll i'll talk about another one the
vikings took a big gamble when they
decided to trade stefan giggs to the
bills
and then use the first round pick they
got for him
on justin jefferson and as well as
dick's is playing in buffalo
i think the vikings feel like it worked
out well for them because
they think jefferson is playing just as
well as diggs
he's younger he's cheaper and they
they really hit a home run when they
drafted
justin jefferson now if some other team
had drafted jeff justin jefferson
ahead of them we might look back at that
trade differently but it worked out very
well for them because
he is i think one of the best rookies in
the league
yeah and javon kindly mds kind of came
in the same way trying to replace a guy
who had been traded and
as the 14th overall pick he hasn't been
that good this year but he had his first
career sack
ended up with 1.5 sacks in the loss of
the saints but played his best game so
far
and the 49ers now are hopeful that maybe
he can catch fire in the second half of
the season
and become what they really thought
javon kinley was going to be when they
used that high pick on him
and he may get some help kyle shanahan
said today that they will put in a claim
for pass rusher tak mckinley who failed
his physical
in cincinnati i don't know why they
would telegraph that maybe they think
there's no one else who claimed him
before who would be ahead of them in the
priority list so they're safe
in letting the world know they're going
to put in that claim one quick point on
jefferson
the vikings did this before when they
traded randy moss to the raiders they
used the pick they got
on troy williamson if you guys remember
him and he was
all due respect awful and i think he had
even more pressure on him because he's
the guy replacing
randy moss well jefferson the guy
replacing stefan diggs and so far so
good
he already has matched moss with four
100 yard receiving performances in his
rookie season my rookie this week
to a tag of iloa look the numbers aren't
spectacular
but they're winning and he is quickly
developing into
the guy he's playing well he's playing
within the confines of the offense
the dolphins have won five in a row and
they are
pushing toward the playoffs and maybe
a division title they benefited as much
as the cardinals
from that hail murray throw because now
the dolphins right on the heels of the
buffalo bills and the afc east and it
could be that
for the first time since 2008 if the
patriots don't win the division it looks
like they won't it will be the dolphins
who won it in 2008 and may get it again
if they keep doing what they've been
doing in 2020 coach of the week time mds
who do you have
well i have a coach that we don't really
talk about all that much in these awards
but he's a guy you may have heard of
bill belichick
who has had so much success that i think
i sometimes think we just kind of
overlook him and forget to talk about
him
when we're talking about a coach of the
week or sometimes coach of the year
he probably should have won more coach
of the year awards than he has
but i just thought he had a great game
plan
his team was ready they hit the ravens
right where they wanted to hit the
ravens and
i really thought that that it was a just
a flawlessly
constructed game plan to beat the ravens
in the best way the patriots could
and you know the patriots they still
have an uphill climb to the playoffs i
mean if you look at
the way the afc shakes out i couldn't
say i think they're going to make it
it it's still kind of a long shot but if
they find a way in
every team in the afc is going to be
saying we don't want to play them
however the seeds play out no one is
going to want to have to play the
patriots
and have a coach after game plan against
bill belichick in the playoffs
mds your guy has lifetime security the
guy i picked mike zimmer we were just
talking a couple weeks ago wondering if
he was going to be fired if not after
this season than he was under fire going
into next season
even after signing that contract
extension and here we are
he's pulling it off again he's got the
vikings played at a great level and you
start looking at their
their schedule they've got a chance to
go the playoffs now
i don't know about that because they
still have a lot of ground to make up
but they could go into the tampa bay
game in three weeks at seven and five
which would be
incredible considering they started one
in five my coach of the week is mike
tomlin and
you know we're kind of taking the
steelers for granted they're just
winning every week i thought the bengals
would beat them i picked against them
twice
this year and in both games it was their
most impressive performances of the
season in blowing out the browns and
then blowing out the bengals
they just win week in and week out
tomlin has them in the right mindset and
i think that the seeds for this
performance
were planted in how tomlin handled it
last year when they lost ben
roethlisberger
no excuses keep fighting keep scratching
keep clawing they almost made it to the
playoffs but i think that mindset from
last year is still there in
every game and they have roethlisberger
so they're just winning and winning and
winning
and if it was the patriots at 9-0 with
these seven games remaining that the
steelers have we'd be saying hey they
got a chance to go 16-0
we need to be saying that about the
pittsburgh steelers all right thank you
to mds
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports